Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P,
one of our viewers, correctly identified
a technique that yesterday's guests,
Darlene Swapper use or the day before
yesterday's guest, Darlene Swapper, used
when I would ask her questions. Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hello, David. I really enjoyed
listening to your interview with congressional
candidate Diane Swapper. Darlene, I wanted to
provide a piece of commentary as to when you were
asking her questions. During the interview, I
noticed that almost every single question that you
asked her, she repeated it in full out loud before
beginning to deliver her answer as a person who is
obsessed with criminal psychology and other forms
of psychology. It probably doesn't come as a shock
to you or many of your viewers. This is a stalling
technique. I believe one of the questions that
you asked her, she had really no responses for
and was formulating on the fly. You know, there is
a possibility she was trying to conceal something,
you know, being that sometimes that is a behavior
that lends itself towards guilt as well as a liar
might need more time to stall for an answer.
But I think she was just woefully ill informed
about a lot of the topics that you discussed.
So thank you so much for bringing us such a.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And she was uninformed and
unprepared. And sometimes, I mean, again,
as I said before one of the questions I asked
Darlene SOFR, the Trumpist candidate was Who's
the current president? That's like a concussion,
brain injury, stroke protocol question.
And she couldn't answer. She couldn't answer
it. And you have correctly identified a common
technique which is stalling. She did a couple
other things, which is at any time you can say
it's not a question I want to delve into. I
don't want to. I don't want to give an answer
because it's controversial in nature or whatever
the case may be. And what's wild is these very
same people don't accept that type of answer
from a Supreme Court nominee. Well, that could
come before the court, so I don't want to answer
it. But when I just say, who's the president,
they think that that's a legitimate answer.
It's wild. It is wild and completely bonkers.
Don't miss today's bonus show. Sign up at
Join Pacman dot com. We will see you then.